hey guys Courtney teza no 4 ET online  now Wonder Woman is a pretty big deal at  the box office and in the DC Universe  only ET caught up with Jared Leto to  find out if the Joker and Wonder Woman  will share the screen one day if I was  only so lucky I saw the film I loved it  I thought it was incredible they did  such a good job  I watched Wonder Woman as a kid and I  really enjoyed it  I was on the road with my band thirty  Seconds to Mars and we rented out a  theater and brought the whole crew and  it was really fun all of us enjoyed it  because there were sacred duty to defend  the world and it's what I'm going to do  now Harley Quinn there's a spin-off in  the works can we see you in that spin  off I have no idea you know I I can't  confirm maybe I know but I can't confirm  or deny there are a lot of moving parts  with that stuff and we'll see what what  happens next  okay honey there's me and you let's do  it